what's going on guys this is Rob and I
want to cover Benjamin Percy's Ghost
Rider because his run is a phenomenal
return to form so like the old Ghost
Rider stories from the 80s and 90s that
were like hyper violent and like just
the whole hell landscape and everything
it was really really cool so we're gonna
do issue number one let me know what you
guys think and if you guys like it we'll
cover the rest so the thing about this
is that Benjamin Percy borrows very
heavily from the centuries origin story
but there are a couple things that we
have to solidify here so one of the
things that Marvel had previously done
is they had made Johnny Blaze the king
of hell he had basically taken over
following the defeat of Mephisto
Mephisto was quite literally Locked Away
In A Cell in Las Vegas because the idea
of Mephisto was to invade Earth set up
uh basically its base of operations in
Las Vegas which seems to make the most
sense right the Devil's Playground is
the nickname that it has and uh he was
ultimately defeated by like doctor
strange and a handful of others and then
his own hotel was turned into a prison
that left hell vacant and basically
Johnny Blaze took it over now of course
in more recent years you actually saw a
kind of turn to form where basically
Mephisto got his throne back and then we
didn't really know what happened to
Johnny Blaze but that's where we pick up
here the Johnny Blaze is back on Earth
but the funny thing about this is that
he's literally meeting with his
therapist now this is what I say that
Benjamin Percy is borrowing very very
heavily from Paul Jenkins and Jay Lee's
the century because the the stories are
almost identical in terms of like how
how Johnny Blaze is coming back that
what happens of course you have Johnny
Blaze talking to his therapist and what
he keeps talking about here is how he
feels like he sees things that aren't
there but he sees things that couldn't
possibly be happening in a lot of ways
it's toying with this idea that he has
schizophrenia and one of the things that
he does in order to kind of quell his
mind and to be able to fall asleep and
keep himself from just seeing these
horrific Visions is that he drinks
alcohol right he literally drinks
himself into a stupor he says when I
drink myself to sleep my brain goes
black like a midnight highway I'm
nowhere I'm just gone hurtling through
the great big nothing until dawn comes
and he says when I don't drink myself to
sleep the nightmares find me I scream
myself awake I sweat through the sheets
I swing at shadows I'm not safe to be
around so most nights I drink if you
fill up a bike with gas you see more and
travel further but if you fill up a
brain with whiskey every drip empties
you further so that when your eyelids
drop you see nothing go nowhere that's
where I'm happiest absolutely nowhere
now this is why I say that Benjamin
Percy is borrowing from from really like
the century storyline the idea behind
the century when he originally popped up
in Marvel Comics is he was basically
struggling with schizophrenia he had
these visions and even these memories of
when he was a superhero but in his
conversations with his wife she would
always remind him like you're not a
superhero and you never were you're just
a guy you're Robert Reynolds you work at
a fast food joint that's all you really
do like that's how your life is you
struggle and so on but literally like
Robert Reynolds would have visions where
he would see things that weren't there
it was a pretty awesome depiction or
pretty accurate depiction rather of what
schizophrenia is like as I understand it
now of course it turned out to be that
Robert Reynolds really was a superhero
and that he had actually had a device
constructed that would block the world's
mind of his existence because so long as
the as the world knew that Robert
Reynolds was the century the void would
inevitably return because they were both
the same person but the thing about this
is that with Johnny Blaze much like what
Robert Reynolds would do he drinks
himself into a stupor it blocks him
blocks out all these thoughts and all
these memories and everything that he
sees because the reality is he doesn't
know if what he's seeing is real or if
what he's seeing is false and the most
terrifying thing here and to really
Compound on this he doesn't know what's
scarier the fact that what he's seeing
may not be real or the fact that what
he's seeing might be real right that it
actually is real and that's really what
terrifies him so one of the things he
talks to his therapist about is that he
was riding his motorcycle and at one
point crashed and basically ended up you
know getting a massive gouge in the side
of his head that just kind of you know
results in like a scar of sorts but one
of the things that he talks about is
like when he walks around like when he
goes out and he does things he sees the
dog that like screams and yaps at him
and the dog like just kind of turns into
a demon of sorts he sees like these
crows and things like that that seem to
indicate like a dark presence and so on
one of the cops or at least the local
local officer rolls up on him and asks
him like do you know what happened to
you know to that dog like to pimp him
because Miss Gunderson or Mrs Gunderson
went out to her mailbox and found the
things next snapped and stuffed into a
stuffed into a mailbox you wouldn't know
anything about that would you Johnny and
he's like no like he makes his way
through like the pharmacy and he looks
through one of those reflective mirrors
right those circular mirrors that they
have in there to make sure that you're
not stealing anything and he sees like
shadows out in the corner he checks
around the corner there's nothing there
there's just a little kid it's things
like that right it's just it's it's
amazing the way that this is handled
because it really quite does it really
does ask the question is Johnny Blaze
actually Ghost Rider like in the story
is he really Ghost Rider anymore or is
it him just kind of seeing shadows and
so on now if you're familiar with the
Ghost Rider Mythos you basically know
what's going on but in terms of anybody
who's never read Ghost Rider once in
their life it's a phenomenal way to get
into the comic and so what we end up
doing is basically jumping to the FBI
and we pick up with a guy who basically
really his name is Agent Wilmer but he
leads what is effectively the Paranormal
unit of the FBI itself now one of the
things to know in Marvel Comics is that
by and large when it came to like
Paranormal Activity and different things
along those lines the government didn't
really have a major presence in that
right ever since like the old project
Wide Awake stories by Chris Claremont
the main focus of the government by way
of shield and different organizations
like that the commission on superhuman
activities and and even just the
government itself like law enforcement
and so on it was really more often than
not focused on super power beings and
mutants that was it the magical side and
the Demonic side of Marvel that was all
handled by like doctor strange and
brother Voodoo and all these different
guys right and so what you have here is
literally a kind of paranormal unit of
the FBI that basically operates on a
shoestring budget which is to say it's
like a one-man operation it's basically
agent Wilmer and like that's really it
the only other person that's involved in
this is a girl who's actually being
introduced in this comic for the very
first time named Talia Warroad and like
that's it we don't really know a whole
lot about it the only thing we know is
that she basically comes from what seems
to be the Paranormal unit of Shield or
was involved in shield in some capacity
well learn more about her as time goes
on if we end up covering the rest of
Benjamin Percy's Ghost Rider but it's
cool because again it really just kind
of gives us this idea that like the
Paranormal unit's there and it is in a
lot of ways kind of a license to do
whatever she wants but truth to tell
like a brunt of the federal government's
resources and really as far as the FBI
is concerned are just focus on other
things right and so it's kind of cool
because one of the things she
establishes is that she hunts monsters
now truth to tell and as I was reading
through this my initial thought is like
okay this was kind of a missed
opportunity to bring back Bloodstone
right like it would have been cool to
see her character make a return having
said that I do like the idea that a new
character is being introduced here I
think it's cool that Benjamin Percy's
going that route but of course one of
the things that happens is if you
basically have Johnny Blaze meeting with
like his father-in-law right and they
just kind of had this conversation and
they're just talking about things and
it's like do you imagine what your life
would have been like if it had gone a
different direction or if you had never
gotten into a crash or anything along
those lines and you were just kind of
doing your thing but in the midst of all
this what you end up having is the
arrival of a guy who quite literally
looks he looks like what's his name from
the stand right I can remember the guy's
name he was uh he was the character that
crossed over everything he was in like
uh the Gunslinger series like the man
the man in Black right but he had an
actual name in in in the stand and I can
never remember his name for the life of
me but uh he literally looks like him
right he looks like that guy and so as
he makes his way through this town this
idea of him being almost demonic in
nature manifests itself when he's kind
of walking by what is basically a kind
of backyard baseball game right an
unofficial baseball game and this kid
like goes to hit the ball and like the
ball gets you know he gets knocked into
a foul and it's like strike three you
know you're out and that kind of thing
and this kid's like that was a foul
right like I barely hit it you know so
on and so forth and that this guy picks
up the baseball he hands it to the kid
it has a kind of demonic face on it and
he's like that kid's a liar man why
don't you show him how hard you can hit
and so that kid seemingly now possessed
runs up on the guy at the pitcher's
mound and just starts bludgeoning him
with a baseball bat this is why I say
this is the old Ghost Rider stuff this
is Ghost Rider from like back in the 70s
and back in the 80s in more recent years
in Marvel Comics The Ghost Rider just
didn't quite have the same kind of like
Pizzazz that he had back in the day and
I hate to use that word because it kind
of makes it kind of indicates like Glitz
and glimmer and beauty and all that kind
of stuff but the truth about the old
Ghost Rider stories man is Marvel didn't
shy away from some really dark
storytelling it was his closest Marvel
ever got to like the old Spawn comics
and even though Ghost Riders and Ghost
Rider stories himself Danny catch Johnny
Blaze those all influence the the Spawn
comics of uh Todd McFarlane so it's
really cool to see that this is kind of
a return to form but this guy's just
kind of walking through the town through
like the middle of the street musing to
himself this is just a perfect little
town right just a beautiful little town
but obviously it's not what it seems to
be right apple pies and baseball and
fireflies and Fourth of July parades and
Sunday sermons but somebody's screwing
somebody they shouldn't somebody's
stealing money from the register
somebody's got a body buried beneath
their Rose Garden the entire depiction
of this town is a lie right this town is
not what it appears to be and so that's
when you switch over to Johnny Blaze
meeting with therapist again and this is
really when Benjamin Percy goes in with
the idea that Johnny Blaze just might be
crazy because as he's coming having this
conversation with his therapist and as
she's asking questions like how are
things going with Roxanne what's your
favorite position Johnny like how do you
like to sleep with your wife just these
really really personal questions that
while a therapist may ask those they
wouldn't ask those so bluntly right and
most therapists would probably only ask
those questions in relation to like how
you view yourself and the life that you
have and maybe to an extent your
relationship but he talks about like she
says she's terrified of what will happen
if I ride the bike again doesn't seem
like I ride the bike around different
things like that that his wife is
concerned about it right and they seem
very much in love their life really just
seems to be perfect right but as he's
having this conversation with his
therapist suddenly like the picture
behind him like it literally turns into
uh to a hog on a spit roast and as the
picture's changing a wolf comes out of
nowhere a wolf starts to eat the hog he
turns around and looks at his therapist
as he sees the pictures weird his
therapist has like this crazy demonic
appearance he goes to attack his
therapist only for him to snap out of it
and realize like it's just her sitting
in this room that nothing is abnormal
and nothing strange right what's wrong
with me and so as he makes his way
through the town and you've literally
just got like all these crazy depictions
of people just being ripped apart and
you've got stuff on fire and it
literally looks like a hellish landscape
Johnny Blaze keeps telling to him that
he keeps telling himself there's no such
thing as monsters my mind's running away
with me this is all insanity or
something like that he gets in his house
his wife and his kids look all demonic
and everything and it's just like none
of this is right you know none of this
seems to be seems to be correct but
there's no such thing as monsters
there's no such thing as monsters and so
she asked him like have you taken your
pills and that again draws on the
element of like Robert Reynolds that
Robert Reynolds was basically a guy who
is on anti-schizophrenic medication if I
remember correctly not gonna swear to
that but literally she's like are you
off your meds because like everything
you're that you're just spouting out of
here seems to be nonsense like this all
seems to be crazy but that's when he
starts to challenge his wife and he's
like I don't remember giving you that
ring how did you get that ring I don't
remember proposing to you I don't
remember any anything anything that
leads up to this life we had I don't
remember it I don't remember meeting you
I don't remember asking you to marry me
I don't remember us dating I don't even
remember us having kids I don't remember
any of these things I just remember
being here one day so what's going on
now of course like while his wife is
terrified scared out of her wits draws a
knife in order to keep herself protected
from her husband Zeb pops up and and
she's like who in the world are you and
he's like my name's Zeb here's my card
right like here's to this card it says
isn't that a lovely ring mind asking me
what it's made of and so literally while
this guy is standing outside the house
then of course Johnny Blaze steps in to
try to protect his wife and so like
literally zip pops up and he was like I
hate to break it to you man but that's
not your wife and this is not your town
he says I hate to be the one to Bear bad
news here man but nothing that you
believe that's going on here is actually
accurate and so when Johnny asks who are
you this guy's response is I'm a scout I
was sent by a group of night magicians
to find you and where Johnny's like
that's a lie this guy's like no you're
the one living the LIE man none of this
is real and that's when he's suddenly
hit by a car and then he reaches his
hand out and says take my hand Johnny
let me show you what's actually going on
let me show you who you truly are and
when Johnny takes this guy's hand that's
literally when he gets this vision of
what the world looks like that in the
absence of the Ghost Rider meaning that
there's no one riding around there with
a spirit of Vengeance punishing the
wicked it's quite literally in a lot of
ways hell on Earth now it's hell on
Earth in a metaphysical form which is to
say the Earth has not been conquered by
demons and that this is all just some
ruse so when Johnny gets out there is
going to be the Avengers are all just
these satanic spawn and all that kind of
stuff it's nothing like that remember
demons for the most part in the Marvel
Universe operate behind the scenes they
possess people they take people over but
they committed all kinds of crazy and
insane acts but Johnny's the one who's
supposed to keep the world protected
from that and that's why Zeb tells him
we need you or rather we need what's
inside you we need the spirit of
Vengeance and so literally what happens
is he says come back to us if the spirit
moves you and then ultimately takes off
right like Zeb just turns into a crow
and flies away and that's when the town
turns to Johnny and says don't listen to
that guy Johnny everything will be okay
okay we'll take care of you right come
back to us Johnny we love you we need
you and so literally Johnny Blaze in
that moment slashes the ring off of his
wife's hand I literally like cuts her
fingers off her hand the ring comes off
she immediately transforms back into a
demonic form and then Johnny picks the
ring up and he puts it on and it's like
boom right like the spirit of Vengeance
re-emerges because what they done is
they had taken the spirit of Vengeance
and confined it inside of a ring cry
literally put it in a cage and so like
literally in demo we get like one of the
best Ghost Rider monologues ever because
Johnny says win that hellstrom of fire
descends on me I realize I'm about to
trade one prison for another when he
takes me over my whole body feels like a
flaming Nest buzzing with hot angry
wasps and I shrink down to a black Speck
at the center and so that's when the
Ghost Rider like this spirit of
Vengeance fully takes over and when he
emerges he is pissed this guy is
incensed right like literally Ghost
Rider is more pissed off than he's ever
been and he's like who did this who
caged me here in this town and literally
like they're like no like don't leave us
like Johnny you have to stay and his
response is Johnny's gone there's no
Johnny Blaze now there's only Ghost
Rider and like literally they jump in to
try to like strip the Ghost Rider off of
Johnny Blaze and it's crazy right
because he's like who did this right
because they're spouting things out like
like it doesn't matter what you do to us
if we do not keep you here it will never
be worse than what he will do right so
just like referencing some enigmatic
Force out there and the response to
Johnny is constantly the same who did
this right like who's he who are you
talking about but at the end of the day
it doesn't make any difference because
wobita the poor bastard that runs up on
on Ghost Rider and decides to start
causing problems right here's the thing
like it's nuts because they thought they
had him defeated right that's the thing
to understand they thought they had the
Ghost Rider locked down right it's like
that guy said to John Lithgow in that
movie Ricochet you didn't beat him you
just pissed him off and now you is
now he's gonna be out for blood and
that's exactly what it is right like
literally he just like grabbed like the
Flaming chain and takes ever like like
he helps he helps these guys understand
their place in the bigger picture you
understand what I'm saying helps them
finish with all their living and
condemns them all back to hell and so at
that moment he says I can't control what
I've become I can only observe it all
distantly like a horror film seen
through a telescope maybe a cluster of
demons broke my brain and spirit
trapping me in a sun-lit prison and
maybe a dark magician broke me out or
maybe this is all just one more
hallucination maybe second now maybe any
second now I'm gonna wake up screaming
or maybe a semi just clipped me and this
whole head trip is one long skin melting
skid across the asphalt before
everything goes dark the only thing that
feels certain is this there is such a
thing as monsters and as the Ghost Rider
I'm the worst one of all so let me know
if you guys want me to cover the rest of
this because it only gets better right
that's why I tell you guys man Benjamin
Percy's Ghost Rider is oh my God it's
amazing but let me know what you guys
think down in the comment section thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace